one of the hardest things to do as a
beginner in programming is read other
people's code and the annoying thing is
reading other people's code is so so
vital to programming like that is
literally how you get better you don't
start off as a beginner just being
absolutely phenomenal by just writing
your own code the way that you want to
write code you need to write other
people's code to get better so here we
are today sitting down to make this
video because I want to tell you guys
what the secret to reading code is or at
least what I think my secret to reading
code is
it's coffee imagine that
uh it's a Sunday kill me and this by no
means applies just to see blast Blast by
the way we're going to be looking at C
plus code just as an example here today
but this applies to everything and that
is would now be a good time to put in
the sponsorship mention no I'll do it
later anyway enough fluff execute the
code run the code stop just reading the
card as if it was some kind of book that
you picked up and you just flipping
through the pages as if it's paper
you're just reading it
don't do that load it up in an IDE load
it up in some kind of like execution
environment that has a debugger and just
run it just run it put breakpoints in
use the debugging like code flow
commands like step into step over all of
that stuff to just kind of go through
the code as it's running I mean you can
think about it this way when you run the
code you're actually getting the
computer to do what the program is meant
to do right so you the computer is
actively literally doing what the
program is doing like the program has
programmed the computer to do something
you're literally watching it do stuff
you're watching it happen so if you can
just kind of like be like whoa slow down
there Cowboy let's just hit the brakes
for a second I'm gonna tell you when you
can do the next thing and I want to
watch you do it that's literally what
you're doing when you run your code
through a debugger like that's literally
what's happening and at that point you
can of course examine the entire state
of your memory you can see what the
variables are set to you can see which
functions are being called you can see
how you ended up in a certain function
by putting a breakpoint in there
assuming the program hits it you can
easily see where the entry point of the
program is and what it does in the
beginning and it's even a much better
way to trace back and find where certain
areas of code are actually written all
of these examples that I just mentioned
we're going to take a look at today here
in this video but first don't click away
don't skip because this is going to be
useful it's going to be important this
video is sponsored by brilliant.org and
the reason why I didn't want you to skip
is because I just want you to know that
currently brilliant.org have a 30-day
free trial free trial 30 days everything
I'm about to say you can experience for
free for 30 days so just check it out
link below brilliant is an amazing
website filled with lots and lots of
really really good high quality courses
on various stem topics there are
specifically two areas that interest me
and that I think can help you and that
is their computer science courses they
have some really really good
introductory computer science courses
that can help you if you're just kind of
starting your programming Journey you
want to ease into it in a really easy to
understand visual way but then also
their mouth courses oh what do I say
about their math courses their mouth
courses are brilliant I actually said
that naturally it just happens to be the
name of the platform as well math in and
of itself can be quite a complicated the
topic and believe me when I say the
brilliant presents it in just such a
beautiful easy to understand way because
all of their courses present information
visually and interactively yeah that's
right they have widgets that you can
play with they have like UI controls you
can slide around so that you can see the
impact that different numbers have on a
graph for example how do integrals work
well look it's here you can play with it
so I just think it's a really good
effective way to learn but also the way
their courses are divided are really
bite size so it's really easy to get
through quickly if you don't have much
time and they'll actively quiz you
they'll ask you questions all along the
way to make sure that you're paying
attention and retaining the information
and all of these features added up
together just make a fantastically
effective learning platform for math and
computer science and they also have
other stem topics as well so go ahead
and check them out as I mentioned 30-day
free trial brilliant.org the churner as
always the first 200 subscribers will
get 20 off an annual membership link
will be in the description below thank
you brilliant for sponsoring this video
alright so back to talking about reading
code I have three examples for you okay
my first example I was doing a code
review a while back this is of like a
ray Tracer I want to use this just as an
example to show that when you have a
function here that calls an object
somewhat indirectly so in other words if
we take a look at this actual code there
are plenty of different objects here
right we have like just the Base Class
object and then we have all these other
classes like mesh which mamesh is an
object we have a sphere which is an
object we have a plane which is an
object if we just go back to this piece
of code that we're interested in and we
want to see what on Earth intersect
object actually does if I try and go to
the definition you can see how many
definitions there are like it can be
really difficult to see if any of them
are even in use if I'm rendering a scene
like which one which function here
applies to what I'm actually visually
seeing because presumably I want to find
out how what I'm seeing is working how
it's actually happening so what I can do
is instead of like instead of like
trying to go through all of that and
find that code if I just put a
breakpoint on this line of code and just
run this program when we hit this line
of code our debugger will pause the
program of course and then I can do a
few things first of all immediately you
can see the Glorious context I'm
presented with in the call stack right
like I can immediately kind of see how I
got there from invoking Main to the
actual main function itself into scene
render into scene launch workers
renderer cast Ray and then render a
trace like I suddenly have so much more
context imagine trying to piece this
together just in your head like it's a
complete nightmare if you've never seen
the code base before and this kind of
thing is the trick that I use all the
time when I'm reading other people's
code for those code review videos that
you're seeing on my channel but it
doesn't stop there if I now want to see
which specific intersect object function
is actually being called I can just use
the step into button over here or press
f11 when I press that you can see it
steps me into sphere intersect object so
I know that I'm rendering spheres and
this seems to be the exact kind of math
that's happening I can kind of read
through that and learn from it but again
it gets better because check this out
all of this kind of context here like
for example if I'm just reading this
code like position minus Ray origin like
l dot dot product redirection what's L
like these kind of parameters can be
difficult to kind of digest right but
check this out I can hover over Ray drop
this down see what the actual numbers
are go through this line by line like
obviously see the result of all of these
variables see which branches are hit and
by the way this is exactly why I would
not write this like that I always drop
these down if it's a one line if
statement with no curly brackets drop it
down like this because then you can
actually see which branch is being hit I
mean in this case obviously we'll know
if it hits this because we'll return
from the function but I'm talking about
like all if statements like this for
example no real way to tell if that's
hit without actually kind of stepping
through it anyway if I keep going you
can see that was in fact hit right
because I'm over here now I'm going to
return from the function so D2 was in
fact greater than R2 and again I can
look at the numbers I can see exactly
what's happening and that of course can
help you tremendously when you're
actually reading and trying to
understand the code now if we just hit
F5 to run this again there's another
trick that you can use in this specific
circumstance because if you press f11
what it might actually do is if there's
like a huge chain here it might actually
step you into the get function now for
whatever reason it didn't I think get I
think because get is actually not it's
part of the standard Library this is
like probably what even is I so I you
can see auto I objects begin we can see
that I is a unique pointer again the
debugger helping us there not too
difficult to work that out from kind of
looking at object vector and saying that
it's a vector of unique pointers but
anyway if you want to avoid stepping
into functions you're not interested in
you can actually right click and then go
to this step into specific menu option
where you can see it presents us with a
few different functions we can step into
now here we can step into this
d-reference operator that's on the
iterator class which will return the
object itself we can go into unique
point to get or we can go into this
indirect call it's an indirect call
because it's a virtual function so if we
click on this guy it takes us exactly
into where we are in this case we're
intersecting a plane so that helps a lot
now whilst we're in this project I want
to show you guys one more thing the way
that this guy wrote this which I pointed
out in my code review which was a little
bit weird is basically if we're in a
debug build we do this on one thread and
if we're in a release build we dispatch
a whole bunch of worker threads to kind
of do this multi-threaded so I'll switch
over to release just because I want to
show you a multi-threaded example once I
hit this breakpoint you can see that
because it is a multi-threaded example
the context has kind of changed this
call stack is now showing that we're not
coming from the main function we're
coming from this thread invoke which
runs this render worker but what I can
actually do to again learn more about
the program understand the program more
and the code is I can go to debug
windows and then parallel Stacks which
is over here and if I do that it'll open
up this useful window which shows all of
my running threads so the call Stacks
for all of the threads because they're
all suspended obviously and it'll show
exactly what they're doing like their
call stack right so you can see for
example the main thread is just sleeping
it's sleeping inside this launch workers
function and in fact I can double click
on that if I want to take a look at that
line of code exactly so I can see okay
sleep for 10 milliseconds okay now I
know how this program has decided to
wait for all of the threads to kind of
finish but you can see the rest of the
threads in the entire program here like
we can see that this guy this guy over
here is doing render retrace and it's
inside the intersect object function
again I can double click on it if I want
to go to that we have like this function
which is like inside acceleration
structure we've got another thread here
I mean all these threads are basically
doing Trace or they're inside cast array
but you kind of get the point it's a
really powerful and easy way to see how
this kind of program is actually coming
together the architecture of the program
now actually example 1.5 because I just
thought of this one more useful way that
you can use that parallel Stacks window
as well is if we go to Hazel this is
going to be Hazel's runtime if I run
Hazel's runtime and specifically
dichotomy a game that we made for last
let him dare which is a game Jam for
those of you who don't know you can see
this is the actual like game being
played if I just with this game running
just hit pause it's going to suspend all
the threads obviously and it's going to
show me the call stack of this so I can
actually kind of get some information on
how on Earth this is running right and
what everything's doing and if I go into
debug Windows parallel Stacks I can also
get some information on how all of the
different threads inside Hazel are
actually working together in that
particular moment so you can see for
example that the main thread is just
inside render thread block until render
Complete because it's just waiting on
the render thread to finish the render
thread over here looks like it's inside
some Vulcan command pool basically it's
trying to upload data to the GPU into a
storage buffer and then we have like the
audio thread which is just sleeping I
can easily kind of see the architecture
of Hazel as well all the way down to
Maine to see how this application kind
of comes together really really useful
stuff that helps you understand how this
code is actually written and how this
program works and hopefully you can see
that if you contrast this to just you
know reading the code just with your
eyes how big of a difference there
really is and how much easier it is to
understand how this works okay the
second example is this this actually
happened the other day I was doing a
code review and I wanted to demonstrate
that unique pointer basically did the
same thing as new and delete it just
kind of automates it it makes it a
little bit more foolproof so we have
this entity class we have us making a
unique pointer I basically kind of want
to just to prove that in the beginning
when we kind of call make unique well
what does it do let's take a look at his
definition I'll hit F12 in Visual Studio
it brings me to the code now it's
standard Staples Library code so
yeah it's a little bit hard to read as
it is and again for beginner good luck
mate poor young China is struggling with
this to all the young churners out there
I salute you this is not alcohol
anyway so you can see very clearly that
the make unique function over here it
takes in our arguments in case we have
any for the Constructor it calls new on
the type that we make unique with so in
this case that would of course be the
entity type it calls new entity and it
passes along any of the arguments that
we have into that Constructor if there
are any very easy to read not a problem
no need to run the code to see that
however I want to show it calling delete
because I know it calls delete right the
unique pointer just calls new and delete
for you right so how do I show that well
back in uh you know the unique pointer
class inside this memory header file
here it is memory there's a nice
intimidating header file if I like you
know if I try and find like the
destructive unique point I'm going to
cheat and use visual assist here alt M
uh and then if I put in like a little
squiggly line here I know that's going
to be the destructor and oh look here's
the unique point of Destructor yeah
that's your call to lead right
um well I mean it calls if my pair dot
my Val to my pair dot get first and then
this looks like the it like get gets
that and then uses like the call
Operator or something on it like what is
going on and again like you know as a
beginner looking at this code like well
I guess I can go to get first that
returns this or what class am I in now
no I mean like a compressed pair of
course I am like what is what is even
happening and why is it calling that
like uh well how does this work well I'm
going back to our code let's execute
this and see how it works so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a
Destructor inside entity right and then
I'm just going to put a breakpoint like
right here you could write some code
here like a print line or something you
could put debug break there's many
different ways to do this I can just put
a breakpoint over here on the opening
parentheses of course make sure you're
in debug as always hit F5 it's going to
compile our code and then we've of
course hit the breakpoint presumably at
the end of this let's have a look at the
call stack because because guess what
how do we call the destructor we call
delete on that object right so if we go
to the call stack and we look at this
you can see that this is us invoking
main right over here then we go into the
unique pointer Destructor we were just
there right so I was right here it is
the unique pointed Destructor we looked
at but then after that we go into like
this SCD default delete operator and
look you can see here that it is in fact
that call Operator that I was talking
about let's double click on that and
take a look at this delete pointer so it
does in fact call delete normally as you
would expect we pass in the pointer
we're trying to delete it goes into the
call Operator this is in the default
delete struct and what it will do is
call delete and you can see just how
easy it was for us to find this exact
code by just using the tools we have
available to us we run the code we put a
breakpoint into where we know it will
eventually end up and then we trace it
back using the call stack really really
effective now as a side note this might
beg the question of like why is it so
complicated why does this not just
delete Point normally the reason why is
because unique pointer is a little bit
more flexible you can actually provide a
custom deleter if you want if you don't
want it to call delete you have like
some special shutdown procedure for
whatever reason it needs to call that
you can pass that in like as a template
argument and it will kind of go through
that process for you that's why it's not
necessarily assumed that this will
happen but rather this is just a default
deleter so there are there are reasons
technically why it's this complicated
but of course if you're new and you have
no idea how anything works it is really
hard to track that down okay and finally
last example example number three is
going to be a quick one Unreal Engine
five nothing quick about this am I right
but anyway suppose you're trying to read
through the code of Unreal Engine 5. now
this is really really difficult to do to
the point where I would probably begin
with the documentation to kind of go
through the actual technical
documentation of how this is architected
rather than trying to read the code per
se but here we are we're in a solution
with 122 projects which is quite a lot
what do we do uh we could start kind of
I guess going through this and trying to
read it maybe I can do a search here for
like I don't know the word main or
something to try and find the main
function like how on Earth do you even
begin with this well I'll tell you how
just hit F10 on your keyboard or go to
debug and then either step into f11 or
step over doesn't really matter I'm just
going to hit F10 I of course have
already compiled Unreal Engine 5 because
if I hadn't then this process would take
hours all right and then when it finally
runs we will see this so I had no files
open before right it was completely
blank it's automatically by itself open
this launch windows.cpp file right and
look at this we're at the beginning of
win main the entry point of the whole
program I can now just go through this
normally by like hitting F10 we can see
here that it's going into the launch
Windows startup function again f11 will
take us into here I can go through this
line by line and actually get a sense of
how Unreal Engine starts up all of the
initialization code I can kind of go
through I can obviously use the same
techniques I used from example one where
I can see what the variables are set to
I can place a breakpoint inside a
function that I'm interested in and then
when the engine on the program
eventually hit it's that function I can
trace it back see the call stack gives
you like at the very least with
something as big as Unreal Engine some
kind of starting point where we can kind
of see what on Earth it does in its
initialization and how it like you know
eventually goes into guided main etc etc
etc hope you guys enjoyed the video if
you did a like would be much appreciated
I really hope this advice was able to
help some people because I just remember
back in the day I really used to
struggle with this and if someone had
just said this I would probably be out
and about reading other people's code a
lot more instead of constantly trying to
write my own instead because reading
foreign code was just too difficult
little Sidetrack by the way the way that
I used to read code as a beginner was I
literally remember printing out pages of
code I printed out pages of code this
was back like in high school I was
really into programming in fact I was so
into it that I printed hours code put
into a display folder took it with me to
camp in like well like you're 11 or
something I was like 16 at the time and
read it like with a flashlight like with
a torch I read it in my tent at night
like paper Java code on paper yeah I uh
yeah I definitely should have just ran
the code